Son días de intensa atención en Italia
después del rechazo del gobierno
italiano al desembarco de los 234
migrantes a bordo del Ocean viking de la
ong eso es meditejané el navío recibió
Este martes la autorización por parte
del gobierno francés de ingresar al
puerto de Marsella al sur de Francia
según Reporta la agencia de prensa
italiana Anza el gobierno italiano
manifestó su satisfacción en un
comunicado de prensa en el cual expresó
su agradecimiento por la decisión
francesa de compartir la responsabilidad
de la emergencia migratoria que califica
como un problema europeo que no solo
concierne a los países del sur de Europa
expuestos por su situación geográfica el
barco debería estar llegando a Marsella
el próximo jueves paralelamente otros
tres barcos humanitarios con abor de
unos 800 inmigrantes han llegado en los
últimos días a varios puertos italianos
todos se han confrontado con la política
anti del nuevo gobierno italiano de
ultraderecha una ejecutivo que ha
decidido permitir únicamente en los
desembarcos selectivos autorizando pisar
Tierra Firme solamente a mujeres a
menores de edad y a pasajeros enfermos o
con necesidades humanitarias
consecuencia de esto en uno de estos
barcos el humanity 1 de La ong alemana
sos humanity 35 inmigrantes siguen
bloqueados a bordo de la embarcación
según Fuentes que se encuentran en este
barco estas personas están sufriendo un
Calvario a bordo padecen de crisis de
ansiedad depresión y han iniciado una
huelga de hambre la ong ha anunciado
acciones legales contra el gobierno
italiano ya que considera que es ilegal
no dejar desembarcar a estos inmigrantes